now probably one of the questions you're
asking yourself i've certainly been
asking myself a lot
as well is where do all of these
emissions people are talking about
carbon emissions talking about getting
down to net zero
but where do they actually come from and
is there a you know a way of comparing
the emissions that we are creating
for instance in our homes with other
stuff coming from the industrial sector
well
actually if you dig down into the data
you can do it and so this is going to be
a slightly longer
sequence than we normally do but it's
really good to just to understand
what this data is representing and how
to compare
emissions from one sector with another
sector because you know actually when
you look at a lot of the focus that we
have
in our news shows and indeed in
newspapers a lot of it goes on things
that actually
don't produce that much admissions
compared with other things that we don't
really talk about that much
so for instance okay this um doughnut
here but i guess it's a donut
represents total global emissions it's
for a few years ago but it's still more
or less representative of where we are
now it's about 50
gigatons billions of tonnes of carbon
dioxide or its equivalent so other
greenhouse gases
as well and if we just start to break it
down let's have a look for instance
land use you can see that over there
it's it's the second biggest chunk
after energy and we'll get to energy in
a second by far the way uh the biggest
but what we can do is break that down
and see where the emissions are coming
from within land use so have a look at
that
that now represents all of land use
and you've got various different bits of
this so for instance look livestock
manure you can see those cows over there
that's 6.8 by far and away the biggest
chunk of it
is uh emissions coming from cattle from
other livestock
as well but just look above that so
above the 5.8 percent 1.3
for rice so specifically for rice
farming that's partly because of methane
that's created during
the process of paddy fields uh
essentially being submerged and then you
have methane coming from the bacteria
1.3 percent of total emissions in the
world
are down to rice really striking isn't
it and you know the question is what can
be done about that then you've got soils
crop burning
deforestation and we'll get to an
interesting comparison about that as
well a lot of talk about deforestation
you're talking about 2.2 percent
uh of total global emissions then
cropland and grassland as well
let's put that back and start comparing
it with other things so for instance you
can see with
waste we're talking about waste here
talking about landfill we're talking
about wastewater emissions coming out
from there
uh various different greenhouse gases
we're talking about
there and now we're starting to look at
chemical processes and it's worth just
saying
what we've got here are the direct
emissions that are caused from
various processes so for instance the
creation of cement that involves
uh burning it in a kiln and you've got a
chemical reaction between limestone
uh that essentially kind of gets gets
rid of the carbon
and that goes off as carbon dioxide so a
lot of carbon dioxide coming out from
the chemical process of cement but
you've also got energy costs as well
we'll come on to a second
but a lot of emissions so chemicals and
petrol talking about 2.2
chemical you're talking uh sorry cement
you're talking about three percent
it all starts to add up and
really nothing can compare with this
though can it so let's take energy
and have a look at where those energy
emissions are actually coming from so
for instance about 16
of all of the energy that we're using in
the in the world
which is creating carbon emissions is
transports the obvious thing of course
is road so road travel
uh almost 12 percent then air at 1.9
percent and shipping 1.7
so a lot of this is transport 16 of our
emissions is down to kind of getting
around
uh around the world and then you've got
buildings so
emissions that are coming out of for
instance are homes that's about 11
of the total uh and then commercial
premises so
and i should say we're talking here
about electricity going into office
blocks we're talking about heating
and indeed air conditioning for these
office blocks and for homes
as well that's about 17 and a half
percent of total
global emissions remember that 50
billion or so of carbon dioxide
emissions that we're talking about here
then bigger than either of those two
things and this is really the
interesting thing here bigger than any
of that is industrial energy
so that is bigger than any of the
buildings that we work in that we live
in
it's industrial work so stuff like iron
and steel blast furnaces 7.2
percent of global emissions comes down
to iron and steel you've got chemical
industry
and we had the chemical industry a
moment ago didn't we when we were
looking at the chemical
process but now consider this that's the
energy
that goes into the process when you're
kind of actually starts setting up a
plant for a chemical reaction
3.6 percent other bits like agriculture
and fishing
uh there's an energy cost as well so we
had that kind of light blue
area about 18 that's just emissions that
are coming directly from the land
and from livestock and so on this is the
energy cost of
actually running an agriculture business
across the world and then you've got
fuel combustion
and oil and gas and top that up and
you're talking about well by far and
away the biggest
chunk of emissions are coming from
energy energetic processes
around the world that we all rely on and
a lot of questions about
you know what we do about that but it is
just worth taking a step back here
because probably you've seen some of
those numbers and wondered well actually
that looks a little bit smaller than i
expected compared to this you know so
for instance
you know we talk quite a lot about
aviation certainly you know we need to
fly less we need to try and
conserve some of those aviation
emissions offset them if you can
that's about 1.9 of total global
emissions
and actually if you remember that's a
little bit lower
than cement so we talk a lot about
aviation don't we we don't really talk
that much about cement and i wonder
whether we should be doing a bit more
discussion
about that or same thing by the way for
deforestation so cement you're talking
about
three percent uh have a look at
deforestation that's
2.2 for deforestation so it just goes to
show
you know what do we talk about more do
we talk about deforestation more or
the production of cement probably
deforestation and there's obvious
reasons for that it's very kind of
telegenic
very photogenic but really we need to
work out a way of making cement in a
sustainable way and right now we're
still very very much at the
early stages of working that out similar
thing if i kind of turn the doughnut
around and we can just
focus on energy in particular have a
look at this so residential now this is
obviously something that affects all of
us in fact you know that 10.9 percent of
emissions
is coming from all of our homes you know
billions of people
across the planet whether it's
electricity whether it's heating and so
on
10.9 percent well what's that equivalent
to
it's actually equivalent to a few
thousand
steel and chemical plants so it just
goes to show you've got a lot of people
affected by this
whereas this is fewer plants incredibly
important for the global economy
but you're talking about equal emissions
and do we focus more on that
the residential side or do we focus more
on steel and chemical
we probably need to think a little bit
more about how we can have green still
if we're going to try and get to net
zero you've got to think about how you
deal with this green steel
how you deal with green chemical
processes because we're nowhere near
actually working that out and certainly
getting that into the mainstream
and then you know i suppose there is
kind of overarching question about why
this matters
uh for places like the uk or indeed the
us where
that kind of breakdown if you look at it
specifically in the uk and this is
global the breakdown in the uk
won't be as dominated by industrial
processes so you might think okay it's
good news in the uk
we're getting our emissions down isn't
that great and certainly yes when you
look at overall
levels of emissions this is just carbon
dioxide emissions in the uk
they are coming down so it starts in
1990
down by about 35 as of a few years ago
they've come down since then but these
are kind of
comparable numbers we're looking at just
came out actually this week um but
here's the thing
that goes down to net zero so that's the
target everyone's aiming for
but these emissions are essentially all
the emissions that are happening in the
uk so domestic
generation of carbon dioxide emissions
and other greenhouse gases
but we also import stuff from overseas
don't we what about that stuff that you
get from china what about the stuff you
get from europe what about steel that we
import
from the continent what about cement
that we import what about all those
other industrial processes
which i just showed you there which we
don't do much of in the uk well we can
still work out how much of that stuff
we are importing and consuming and if
you do that
the total footprint so not just looking
at domestic stuff but looking at stuff
we consume
is a lot higher so that is our all of
the emissions we're basically
responsible
for so below the white line is in this
country and
between those two lines that's emissions
from imported goods
around the world and you can see the
line first of all is a lot higher second
of all
it hasn't fallen as fast as that white
line which is the white line basically
that net zero is all about
and if we want to get down to net zero
on that well it's going to be a lot
harder because you have to try and
you know cooperate with other countries
you have to try and persuade them to cut
emissions
which we're not necessarily able to do
so you can see this is the more you look
at it the more complicated it gets
but we need to focus on this kind of
data whether it's looking at total
domestic emissions and just remembering
that there's also imported goods
or whether it's looking at where those
emissions are coming from it's a really
powerful thing to remember
it's not just about deforestation it's
not just about aviation
it's not just about those things you do
in your home it's also about
cement it's about steel it's about
obscure processes
which we really need to focus on and try
to remake if you're going to get down to
net zero you need to remake them and
re-imagine
the industrial revolution all over again